hallo leute ich es wieder einmal waren
und willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender festigen video und ja
ich weiß es ist oktober aber irgendwie
hat mich in kommentaren gefragt ob ich
auch dieses jahr wieder adventskalender
auspackte und dann dachte ich so hessler
oktober und dann habe ich geschaut wann
mein letztes adventskalender video
online ging
und das war auch im oktober und falls
ihr euch erinnern könnt das ging auch
platz eins in die trends also okay wir
haben nicht mit 2016 wir haben 2009 10
und für 2009/10 finde ich so einen
rummel nennt man kalender bisschen
schwierig versteht mich nicht falsch ich
finde schon dass männer und frauen
irgendwie unterschiedlich sind ausnahmen
bestätigen immer die regel aber ich hab
so ein bisschen angst dass hier so ein
bisschen schminke schwinke drin sein
wird und hier werkzeug ich würde mich
niemals als typisches mädchen
beschreiben weil ich finde sowas gibts
nicht wirklich es gibt halt die mädels
die of pink und glitzer und mate und
diese kleine hunde stehen und es gibt
die mädels die fußball spielen und gerne
klettern und bier trinken und da bin ich
so ein zwischending also ich kurz gerne
rum und trinken bier aber ich liebe es
auch meine fingernägel zu lackieren und
ob diese gar nicht mal anschauen dürft
ihr versteht was ich meine und als sie
nach adventskalendern gesucht habe sind
mir die sofort ins auge gesprungen und
ich finde die besten wir heute also der
klingt schon mehr wie ein werkzeugkoffer
und der nicht aber wie gesagt wir
vergleichen sie einfach miteinander wir
gucken was franzis denkt was frauen und
männer an ihrem adventskalender haben
wollen ladies first wir machen türchen
nummer 1 von den frauen als kalender
wer gerade das ist wieder verlassen dass
ich liebe weihnachten ihr wisst es genau
stell dir mal ein bisschen es sieht aus
als ob sailor moon gehören würde
sie sind green ich habe keine ahnung was
das ist
jede gute sache hat einen haken ach so
ist das hier kennt ihr das
das legt man auf dem tisch und dann kann
man seine handtasche so dranhängen ich
würde sagen dass schon frauen produkt
weil also ich kann nicht so viele männer
mit handlauf muss mögen aber ich finde
dieser glitzersteine ist ein bisschen
übertrieben macht es nun schlag auf was
haben wir dann für die männer ein
türchen ein ok kriegen eins für mich ein
bisschen uhr fände ich wusste es also
ich freu mich gerade über das männliche
türlich hinein
es ist ein kreditkarten schutzmann packt
seine kreditkarte hier rein und dann ist
sie geschützt vor
ich glaube wenn man zum beispiel am
flughafen ich bin mir nicht sicher vor
anderen sachen sie auch geschützt ich
bin so ein bisschen schwieriger weil
dieses typische armani kreditkarte
bekommen heutige ich erst mal shoppen
dieses viele kabel und ich brauch kein
man schon zu gehen was bekommt die frau
an türchen nummer zwei in den büchern
steht das ganze ausmaß der katastrophe
begreifen
ist nicht deren ernst am 2 dezember wird
man schon daran erinnert dass man
wahrscheinlich zu alt geworden ist das
maßband weil wir fragen wir dass uns ja
nur gedanken über unser gewicht und es
winkt machen nachdem ich fühle mich so
triggert ok willkommen die männer jetzt
auch ein maßband wenn du mal wieder alle
hände voll zu tun hast unsicher was du
damit machen kannst ja bin ich
ich finde es einfach nicht es ist ein
haken eine band außen ist kann er mehr
vielleicht waren machen
vielleicht was den top speed grip sorgen
nein ich glaube es ist so was wie ein
schlechter pop so könnten drei für die
frau na klar ich brauche natürlich eine
nagelfeile türchen 3 für den mann
[Gelächter]
die männer so viel coolere sachen handys
ist super geil
das ist schraub aufsätze also
schraubenzieher aufsätze schraubendreher
aufsätze sind schraubendreher oder
schraubenzieher
[Musik]
na ja auf jeden fall ist es wie ein
stift getan und man kann seine ganzen
aufsätze da rein tun und man hat immer
unterwegs schraubenzieher women's nummer
vier schlafmaske die schlafmasken männer
also während die männer einen like it
ich habe schon vermutet es ist ein
portemonnaie und dann dachte ich lebe
ich noch mal wasser steht steht dir wenn
du bezahlst also ich hab noch gedacht so
ja da steht women's adventskalender wird
wahrscheinlich auch viel schokolade oder
hier wird ein bisschen mehr im whisky
sein da wird ein bisschen mehr sekt sein
wann weiß er was frauen und männern so
ein bisschen mehr mögen aber wirklich so
eine helle die ganze zu kriegen
[Musik]
aus alt mach stylish wer könnte es
besser ein gutschein für ein e book mit
dem ich basteln kann also upcycling
glaube ich gibt männer nummer fünf wer
hätte nicht gerne mal ist ein ebook
download gutschein für kaffee also dass
man lernt wie man kaffee macht ist
beides nicht so doll aber ich weiß ja
ich bastel gerne deswegen dankeschön
nikolaustag nummer sechs ist groß an
nikolaus bekomme ich auch ein
portemonnaie gestreift zum schlanken
geldbeutel
das ist praktisch wenn man feiern geht
das darüber freue ich mich schlanker
geldbeutel
mein portemonnaie es immer bett lief das
ist stand zunächst aber ja ich kann die
kohl aus dem portemonnaie und was kriegt
der mann am nikolaus wenn du mal wieder
ganz auf sich alleine gestellt ist weil
männer sind immer auch sie alleine
besteht ja ich glaube einparken und
einen kompass und trinkflaschen halter
ok beruhigen uns jetzt aber auch mal
wieder und geben dem ganzen eine chance
muss aber ganz kurz falcon habe ich am
handgelenk schon zugenommen habe er
passt noch du darfst auch würfeln lassen
du darfst auch würfeln lassen aber
eigentlich ist es ein würfel für dich
ich bin so gelangweilt dass euch jetzt
machen spülen
super und jetzt sauber machen kochen
einkaufen freizeit was du darfst auch
würfe kriegt mein ehemann und werden
aber jeden tag dürfen was er zu tun habe
die nummer 7 für den herren das find ich
cool und flaschenöffner mit korkenzieher
superklasse parma perfekt zum mitnehmen
türchen nummer acht
ich erwarte ein popstar zu bekommen ich
glaube es ein popsternchen pop sockel
ist aber der woche kriegt so schnell ab
denn nummer 8 für den mann
cool bleiben
plötzlich wird er gut alter das ist
jetzt wieder für man noch für frau geil
chilli schlüsselanhänger wenn es schon
beim hinsehen juckt alkohol
reinigungstücher ob sie mein toiletten
wenn es schon beim hinsehen jungen
einzige was wirklich juckt ist er unten
die haut ja also wirklich diese zwei
ipads ist es so gut und was bekommt er
her geilen teppichmesser kann es
nächstes jahr wieder auch wenns kalender
so ein tierchen du machst eine
taschenlampe ja von die praktisch finde
ich abends draußen verwenden wenn ich
mal wieder im wald bin nur wenige
zentimeter einen großen unterschied
machen können das ist so ein krieg
länder ich kaste aus 20 zentimeter wie
im leben kleiner peter hab ich das alles
hier so anschaut sieht es so aus als ob
ich kämpfen ging wurde
ohrstöpsel praktisch aber auch träsch
eigentlich nicht entfernen diese
aufkleber ist tragend das ist ein
sticker wo draufsteht nicht entfernen
dieser aufkleber ist tragend nochmals
welt für die frauen die heute packe ich
mal wieder ein paar mini kekse also ok
führt eine kitchen sie seien sie gerufen
wird es verwenden wozu soll ich das noch
verwenden nummer 12 für den man bekommt
er auch nudelholz rubik's cube
mittlerweile habe ich sehr akzeptiert
dass sie zwei adventskalender wer in
klischees denken aber jetzt ist das neue
problem es ist halt auch nur müll drin
13 eine reise zahnbürste
okay ein ebook download gutschein motor
klassiker erfahren sie in 80 portraits
alles über faszinierende automobile und
ihre motoren mit den e-books haben dies
auf jeden fall fehlen wikio an diesem
samstag präsentiert ihnen franzis mit
kooperationen in rio ein rezept für
wunderbar natürliche specials kraft ein
rezept für technik scrubs kann ich auch
auf youtube gehen gibt es drei millionen
stück von deutschland wahr ist dieser
kalender müll du kocht und putzt und
machst alles und ich sitze in meinem
sessel und finde es gut der junge mit
der scheiße auf die gedanken sind frei
sind magnet es sind zitat von helge
schneider ok wow 15
endlich mal wieder ein highlight im
welthit ist doch schön dass sie
wenigstens denkt man sich lesen kann
das ist eine kleine land für mein buch
tut ist so praktisch still sondern
machst du das drauf und dann leuchtet
ist dein buch an 15 für den kern jeder
braucht einen platz zum träumen
also wollte ich schon immer mal haben
das ist mit geld klammer ja da machst du
deine geldscheine rhein und maas will
ebay verkauft 40 euro leute hab damit
ihnen die geld klammer leute da meine
damen und hänge vom die 16 jetzt kommt
die 16 wir die 16 da ist die 16 für die
frauen als gott den wand erschuf übte
sie nur sogar bis eine frau gerade so
war
warum muss es sein bis ans andere
geschlecht sein warum kann da nicht
stehen carpe diem oder so finde ich viel
cooler
ich packte blieb ist klein in die
handtasche ich liebe das wenn man
irgendwo der ba sitzt oder so und dann
so ein bisschen karten spielen kann und
ich bin sein glas reinschaut 17 für die
frau aus ganz grob jud ist ein notizbuch
des imbisses notizbuch er steht vor dem
wohnen drauf und dann strömt ist trumpf
männer das gut ist und meine und
strümpfe anziehen also das doch so
unangenehm wenn ich in der strumpfhose
an haben ist dass wir das unangenehmste
von den schuhen besonders mit diesem
kunststoff stumpf ist trumpf 18 neue
männer braucht das land ich sag mal neue
adventskalender braucht das land 18 für
den magen
wir passen uns den kopf tief verschneit
war das nicht cool wie sonst nur 1 19
öfter mal was scharfes tragen ja
koopmann kleines so art schweizer
taschenmesser das praktisch gut ist aber
auch so ein p die nicht mal ein euro
artikel 19
wahre liebe rostet pflege okay das weiß
ich weiß nicht was man mit dem zeug
anfangen wollen das sind echt aus wie
etwas aus meinem dad irgendwo in der
schublade hat einen schlüsselanhänger
doch einfach bei uns sexismus ganze
banane marek zu den bahnstrecken für
männer
ich glaube es ist irgendwie ein kabel
zusammen zu halten oder so ich bin schon
enttäuscht
21 gruppen vergoldete jedes wort von mir
nicht mein bank gibt es dazu die männer
bekomme 21 das große fest dressing für
deinen kopf salat
doch das ist mal wieder kategorie bin
ich lieber habt sagte die borussen royal
coal corp
22.1 mit bildern im kloster also damit
der kleinlich vergisst dass man ja im
winter ging den vollen zum stehen
maintal red bull ring real oviedo bringt
geist und fleisch in einklang
faszination grillen das ebook 23 socken
ja wisst ihr woran ich das erinnert an
diese probe sorgten niemand im
schuhgeschäft anziehen muss wenn man
barfuß reinkommt damit man nicht barfuß
in die schule rein geht rein
klein trage diesen regen als zeichen
seiner liebe nicht cool
alles ist mehr regen als flaschenöffner
verließen kannst du hast mir leider
nicht völlig aber leiste man so weist
man jetzt mit freunden in spe die geben
papier trägt und so und nun sind wir
beim allerletzten türchen angekommen
nummer 24 heiligabend was braucht die
frau da rock'n'roll baby class and bust
es brauche jetzt erstmal bei dem
showtanz kalender
das ist geil massagen roller fürs
gesicht gut für die durchblutung hammer
teil
so und jetzt kommen wir zur 24 für den
mann was kriegt denn der mann an
heiligabend zu weihnachten nur das gute
besteck merry christmas zu weihnachten
das gute besteck beschiss hallo ich
fühle mich so war die frau bekommt
dieses schweizer taschenmesser und der
mann dieses dach meines körpers hier
wurde schon hier dieses coole flaschen
teil bekommen hat und noch mal und noch
mal schwarz hier
ich kann aber nicht genug raum für haben
von oben gespült den kern sprach ein
großes messer also so ein scheiß ich
fühle mich wirklich betrogen und belogen
von diesem adventskalender mein fazit
kauft euch diese adventskalender nicht
nicht nur aus dem grund dass man sich
schon am zweiten tag auf händel fühlen
weil man auch sein gewicht angesprochen
wird
es ist halt auch einfach nur schrott ich
bin wirklich ein toll ich meinen sohn
paar sachen finde ich ja auch ganz gut
und so eine passage roller ist doch auch
eine nette idee oder sonst was auch
wahrscheinlich nicht so toll ist oder
auch im flachland meinetwegen oder auch
vom anfang dieser türen dieser
handtaschen halter praktisch aber seine
sticker oder so ein kleiner plastik
würde und dass hier sowieso alles kommt
hier in plastik verpackt an und dann
link dann nur eine lose an der tür
geklingelt es mein perfektes noch nicht
vorbei
[Musik]